こんにちははじめしゃちょーです
寝てる
間にバレずに
家の中に
回転寿司作れる作れない
[音楽]
はい皆さんは
回転寿司というものをご存知でしょうか
あれは普通のお寿司とはわけが違います
回転してますあの回転により何人の人間が
犠牲になったことかあの回転のこの謎の
魅力より多くの人が回転寿司屋さんに足を
運びお寿司を食べるあれは1つのこう
なんか
心理的なやばい作用があるのではないかと
研究では言われてますそこで私は思いまし
たなんか最近回転寿司お家でもできる
らしいんですよで今回その回転寿司はお家
でするにあたって深夜の
後輩たちが寝てる間に回転寿司屋さんを
作れるのが作れないかちょっとやってみ
たいと思いますというわけで今回
後輩を2人実験内として準備しましたこの
2人には昨日の夜中から別に食べ物も
あまり食べさせずもう今日の夜になったら
バタッと寝ちゃってなかなか起きないん
じゃないかぐらい結構
追い込ませましたVTRこちらですどうぞ
なのでかなり眠りは深いし起きないと思い
ます家の中に回転寿司を作ること自体
かなり変なんですけどもカチャカチャ音が
したりとか酢飯の酢の匂いだけで起きる感
をちょっと心配なんですけども果たして
後輩が寝てる間にバレずに回転寿司が作り
きることはできるのかどうか早速やって
いきたいと思いますでは行こう
はいというわけで二人ともお疲れ様でし
たー
大体どれぐらいですかね24時間近く
起きてるんじゃないでしょうか
超えてますね余裕で想像したり眠いという
ことでぜひ疲れてると思うのでゆっくり寝
てくださいおやすみおやすみなさいお
やすみなさいお腹すいてます
[音楽]
続いてます
おやすみ
[音楽]
まさか
はいただいまの遅刻深夜の12時27分
ですこんな夜中にお寿司が食べられる家
ないですよというわけで
深夜に寝ておきたら
目の前が回転寿司になっているとき
早速起こしていこうと思いますありがとう
ございます
[音楽]
あいらっしゃいません
お客さんどうぞ席の方へこちらになります
どうぞ
よろしくお願いします
逆にいらっしゃいますなんだけど
いらっしゃいませんおはよう
ございますおはようございますいいんです
かというわけで
深夜に起きたら
目の前がお寿司屋さんになってるとキリ
でした
[音楽]
ありがとうございますすみませんこんな
山遅くに今何時ですかこれ今ですね時間の
方が12時30分です
夜中ですああどうですか
いらっしゃいませって聞こえたんですけど
あのいらっしゃったなこちらです
寝起きで茹でえって
[音楽]
寝起きでも寝起きでもよかった私も
いただきます
店員さんじゃないいらっしゃいました
ちなみにこの時間にお仕事されてたことは
あまり
本当に初めてかも
始めていただきました原付さん大無理させ
てるやん
本当にすいませんだけど
夢じゃない
すごいおすすめはねあのマグロ3種盛り
みたいな
いただきます
超美味しそうなんだけど
[音楽]
いただきます
家で食べてるっていうのとさ時間とさこの
特別感でめちゃくちゃ嬉しいんだけど
すごい意外と寝起きでも人は順応できる
なら回転寿司に
起きてスースー食べてるのすごいマジで
うまい
寝起きですよちょっと
次のお客さんもいるのでたくさん食べ
ちゃってください今のうちにいただきます
もう1人後輩上で寝てるので早速連れて
行きたいと思います
[音楽]
3階まで来れそうすぐ
すぐこれで3階よしすぐ来るんだぞ
わかった
もうすぐ来ていいよそれが来てね
[音楽]
いただきます
お客様
申し訳ございません閉店のお時間
ありがとうございましたありがとうござい
ます
本当に
[音楽]
はいというわけで今回深夜にお家に
回転寿司を設置してみたわけなんです
けれどもなぜなぜ深夜にやったかと言い
ますとこちら
ディマンドリスポンスでございますはい皆
さんディマンドディスポンスとは電気って
電気を作る量供給量と電気の消費量が同じ
量になってる必要があるんですでもしこの
バランスが崩れてしまうと正常な供給が
できなくなってしまうんですでこの
バランスを保つために
消費者が賢く電気の使用量を制御すること
で電力需要パターンを
変化させることを
リバウンドリスポットですということで
今回はあえて起きるではなくみんなが寝て
いる深夜にドッキリをさせてもらいました
この冬ですね資源エネルギー庁では節電
プログラム促進事業を行っているらしく
実際の節電によってなんとポイントなどの
特定がもらえるみたいです他にも日々の
電力仕様の見直しにつながったり社会の
損失を防ぐ社会的な意義があるので皆さん
もぜひ参加してください
よーし僕たちも参加するぞ
せーの
[笑い]
[音楽]